the joy of a new voyage far across the
sea of thieves just you the wide open
world at our buckle is not just you
she's here too
oh and this guy's here but the point is
this is a shared world right for
exploring and reading with your fine
pirate crew
look at them scurrying around making
themselves useful that's what we like to
see
the world of sea of Thieves seeds with
possibilities with adventures skulking
above and below the waves all you have
to do is jump in and up there she goes
[Music]
few things tend to pirate like the siren
song of a lootable ship rank careful
though there could be anything down
there
literally there could be anything we
haven't finished designing it yet joking
that was a joke ah sunken treasure is
like a pirate performance points
every players decisions and discoveries
will be different but however you plan
on seeking your fortune it pays to be
prepared for gigantic lumps of iron
these are surprisingly portable amazing
workmanship anyway
bear get them back on board while the
coast is clear there's really no sense
in pushing your luck down here and that
is not a beast you want to pick a fight
with yes it's possible to take on these
two thee't errors of the deep you're not
much used to your crew betting in two
sometimes a tactical key is perfectly
acceptable in the spirit of that
legendary pirate captain pathetic tea
[Music]
thankfully for every tense standoff
there's a moment of celebration for
shared wonder but for now
store your hard-earned loop and enjoy
the voyage on Devil's right beneath the
sands the gold lies hidden from thieving
hands no that's typical look here we are
at Devil's Ridge nice transition by the
way
and so you ship from the heart of the
sea to the island shore where you'll
explore jungles and coves clef tops and
caverns every region has it's very own
landmarks and over time you'll uncover
hidden shortcuts abandoned stashes and
Vestas they'll steal your grog soaked
breath away and yes
sometimes you'll encounter people who
for whatever reason would like to blow
you into little pieces
that's pirating for you keep that pestle
cranked because you'll also face the
roaming remains of those Raiders who
came before you got shot in pursuit of
their own legends
and after life of fighting and trouble
McLean tell all your bets fall it's what
it would have wanted now make sure your
crewmates all depart to play yep that
works and look they brought the riddle
map seek the cursed borscht rain where
there is no sky it lies and wheat for a
length held high right well that's gotta
be around here somewhere
but if you've got bad feeling you can
always leave someone on board to brace
the ship for a speedy galley decisions
decisions
ah looks like they've snuffed out that
place where there's no sky time to pool
your resources as you plunge into the
unknown it would be easy to come a
cropper in these claustrophobic caves
you don't want to wander off track
unless of course you're streaming and
you'll have loads of people in the chat
telling you what to do anyway
Diane is probably not just kids
of course the premier plunder isn't just
lying around to be clean by any old
drunken bumbler you'll need to watch out
for likely locations following your map
clues and your instincts to make a light
work of each new mystery
late work well Lantern took their you're
welcome anyway step 11 paces Northwest
through the gloom beg my chest from its
tomb and with that we're one step closer
to payday
then again some of the loot in these
parts has lain undisturbed for a long
long time that has to be the spot you
can practically taste the treasure good
call on a double duty shovel work to
that store mate says was nipping at your
heels ah very nice
of course the trouble with treasure as a
rule is that the owners really like to
hang on tests if you've got your hands
full it's up to your crew to watch your
back and while they're doing that it's
time for another strategic withdrawal
with the loot nope no that way that's it
easy no
don't stop keep going almost there watch
that next step is a doozy
that's a rescue
[Music]
if you can regularly beat the odds and
get chess back to your ship you'll be
able to turn a tidy profit by trading
them in and out cause that's just the
tiny matter of making it through this
storm in one piece
[Music]
[Music]
all pirate life is here on the sea of
thieves and you can let yours however
you want so rally your crew
Saints Aylmer wretches and M famiy
become a pirate of legend
just try not to be this one
[Applause]